uh my friends being annoying as [ __ ] and
my teacher he was like hey uh Chris let
me talk to you outside real quick yeah
yeah they go outside and you just hear
him go like this and slam him again
shut the [ __ ] up in class
[Music]
so all right this is a tough topic so
brace yourselves it's not as happy oh
[ __ ] man let's talk about sex instead we
did that the last like four videos Karen
get out of here
before he even finished
so um oh man so two teenagers uh in Iowa
recently got a bad grade from their
Spanish teacher because they didn't
speak Spanish right you know they didn't
read write because they didn't speak
Spanish right but let's just say that
they got a bad grade and so they got
frustrated so they did what uh no other
teenager would do and they killed her oh
[ __ ] were they Asian no they weren't no
what that's great I mean finish your
sentence just to see how disgusting
people kill themselves when they get it
back that's right that's right this
might be white kids
there you go that might be white oh yeah
but they're they respect the covet
protocol
that's good that's good okay I like how
he matched his mask with his hair
I was gonna say are those what are those
best Straight Jackets they look like
yeah they look like straight I was gonna
say that's kind of hard I like that they
respect Dr fauci but they are cool with
murder
trying to find the bright side I like
how everything you said isn't a question
mark interesting but doctor they color
coded though the brunette was like with
the black one and then the blonde was
with the yellow gold and then they're
like
um so how did they kill this this
teacher so this teacher uh her name was
nohima Graber
these two teenagers uh
I don't see their eyes real quick but
they look like they're 15. yeah let's
just say let's just say if they're
learning if they're 16 17 now Spanish
starts in high school there it is yeah
it's a high school okay for sure
um they uh murdered a nohima Graber in
Fairfield a town about you know so far
away from Des Moines and uh basically
graber's body was found in a Fairfield
Park on November 3rd in 2021 hidden
under a tarp wheelbarrow and railroad
ties she had been beaten to death with a
baseball bat oh God and Miller and good
old uh Goodale they're they're team
names we're 16 at the time oh
investigators found that Miller met
Graber at Fairfield High School on the
afternoon of November 2nd 2021 to
discuss his poor grade
Graber later drove her van to a park
where she was known to take daily walks
after school they scouted Witnesses saw
the van leaving the park less than an
hour later with two males in the front
seat the van was left at the end of a
rural road after a phone call from
Goodell a witness picked up Goodale and
Miller as they walked to town on that
road
the police interview Miller described
frustrations with the way Graber taught
Spanish and over how the grade in her
class was lowering his GPA
quote the poor grade is believed to be
the motive behind the murder of Graber
which directly connects Miller so it
literally was nothing short of they got
bad grades so they took a baseball bat
maybe she was a teacher like Peggy Hill
yeah and like her Spanish was a little
[ __ ] you know and then they're just
like come on dude this ain't real
Spanish I love the double standard of
they're so mad that they're getting
their GPA lowered and the concern for
their future leads them to do something
that [ __ ] their life even worse yeah
great logic and I want to call nerds you
know but I can't put them in a box
because they [ __ ] murder their
teacher with a baseball bat so they kind
of G like that like it's crazy like
they're gonna be tried as adults they
should be
that sounds like some Mafia [ __ ] like
they've done it before the way they
killed her is crazy yeah but they hit
her under too many things that's stupid
they're gonna see that faster sorry I
didn't mean to sound like a sociopath
yeah they just put it under a park yeah
both teams now 17 will be tried as
adults in Iowa the penalty for our first
degree murder conviction is life prison
nah they should just kill him oh damn I
don't know I have a theory I used to
believe in that but then like if energy
cannot be destroyed
only transferred right and if we believe
in this they got bad energy these guys
got bad energy we need to trap them for
as long as we could in that body because
once it releases it will be embodied in
something else what if we trap him in a
volcano I'm down or freeze them let's
freeze them
the Ice Cube but what about that
perpetually burning hole that's in like
Russia or some [ __ ] yeah someone's there
bro because they [ __ ] scouted her and
everything they plan this out man and
they like jacked their van and drove it
to another location I don't like it at
one bit were they adopted by Asian
parents or something why they got so
much stress about grades and [ __ ]
usually yeah you'd think kids that would
do something like that wouldn't care
about their grades so it's such a
contradicting thing that's really really
strange and how are you both failing
Spanish like why don't care if they just
[ __ ] help each other
or take a different language get a
[ __ ] tutor also too the internet bro
you can't you can't learn Spanish on the
internet you download babbles you know
what I'm saying is that a sponsor yeah
[ __ ] just kidding me who's you know
what we're missing here we don't have
these kind of kids on the west coast but
I guarantee you they're like the East
Coast boat shoes boys you know the boat
shoes boys that goes to Ivy Leagues yeah
and then they they
um they had to do it to them guys yeah
yeah yeah they had the double collars
yeah yeah the the guys that wear um
Hollister yeah and and I'm like all
right the boat shoes kids
that's that's the that's them
they need to go to Yale yeah and they
can't fail nice see that's them but also
though like
just get just get better at Spanish it's
not that hard that's the thing I'm
actually bothered about because it's
like Spanish looks learning another
language is hard but like learning
another language when we were in high
school was harder 100 but nowadays like
I said going back to the internet
there's just so many [ __ ] resources
resources out there kids don't think
like that though they should these
[ __ ] guys they're probably looking at
porn all day you wanna know cut into our
brand deal dude [ __ ] Babble
honestly don't kill your teacher get
Babel get Babel dude you know what's the
fun do anything else but kill your
teacher the the comedy side of this
would be like right before he like kills
her she's like what are you doing and he
goes adios Nosotros
he says
the la vista baby
adios
that's not correct
you have to try so hard to say adios no
socials that's so much difficult maybe
it's not just like that she was she
might have been how was her teaching
yeah because it's kind of like Peggy
Hill still doesn't make sense I remember
taking Spanish in high school and I felt
like it was too hard because the teacher
was a natural like she grew up speaking
Spanish yeah yeah and I don't think that
becomes a good teaching thing like when
it comes natural to you yeah just like
Math teachers it's a little not fair
yeah like all the math teachers I had
they were all like [ __ ] Geniuses
right so they look at us like we're
[ __ ] dumbasses because we don't
understand math but they're not like
speaking our language I think it makes
it harder when a teacher makes you feel
like why can't you get this idiot I feel
like teachers that are like that I'm
like why are you even teaching we don't
know [ __ ] that's why we're here you
stupid [ __ ] yeah we're not coming in
here knowing everything well that's the
bigger problem though right like
teachers have it hard right they paid
nothing so that's why we got okay
teachers yeah and but then that's also
where you could tell the difference
between teachers that do it out of lack
of another app application for their
skill and teachers that just love
teaching that's also why I feel like I
learned a lot from substitutes because
they would come in and try yeah yeah I
thought they just came in and rolled in
the VCR I got both I got both those are
also the best ones too they are the best
I like that well no what I did in
Spanish this is a true story me and my
friends I didn't do that well in Spanish
either but I had really good grades
growing up but I would get like a B in
Spanish we figured out how to um control
the TV like through an app so we would
always like mess with her and like put
stuff on the TV and like distract it
um but that's the furthest we went was
just like did you put up stuff
that would [ __ ] me up if I was a statue
who did this
bye we
yeah but also too it's like just cheat
that's what we did yeah cheat we we
found all the native Spanish speakers
and we just [ __ ] how you can't cheat in
this day and age with so many tools oh
my God it's very sad you're not even
trying like murders your next move try
harder yeah yeah like oh I don't know
what to do these kids are fragile that's
why it sounds personal it sounds like
she made them feel shitty yeah and so
through that it wasn't because of bad
grades I think she was just being a
[ __ ] dick to them and then they were
like you're gonna be sorry and dead also
though even if they were like okay bad
grades we have to murder her that's
still not going to change their grade
they're still gonna have the same grade
in the system would change their grade
afterwards just to hack the computer I
think these guys I think these kids are
for a lack of a better word star worded
they're are worded you know yeah a
little bit you know that's smart but in
a very they're rejected they're so
rejected
they probably are I think they just
developed them that's for sure they
should put them in a volcano like what
bird said did you ever get in a
situation where you wished ill will on
your teacher yeah all the time every day
you figure it out dude I always did but
I never did anything yeah I do remember
being like these kids and being like man
when I [ __ ] get old enough I'll [ __ ]
you up man yeah wait till I grow up and
then later I was like I was a piece of
[ __ ] man I deserve that kind of bullying
from my teachers yeah but you really
never did anything not even like a prank
oh to inconvenience them I know no no no
no no no no never but I would always do
things obliviously
like um so I remember in my senior year
in high school me and my friends we uh
we went camping and then we took this
picture with all of us our butt cheeks
facing the camera we took with all of
our uh butt sticking out great and then
uh I just had like those pictures on my
desk and the teachers are already
looking at I'm like oh check this out
and then she sent me to the office for
sexual harassment oh
later on you're asking to see her for
sure well she asked me
trying to protect herself huh yeah she
had I would predict myself too I'd be
like dude this is funny but uh in 2022
like I'm [ __ ] if I don't do something
as a teacher did you guys have any
teachers that would like were like
quote-unquote cool teachers yeah I love
that teachers that would like smoke pot
whoa that's too cool okay too cool they
would like meet up with them at like no
way near Henninger and they'd like smoke
pie uh so my best friend in high school
he was kind of annoying and then uh we
decided to join ASB like our senior year
to try to make a change or whatever and
I thought to the government yeah and I
thought our ASB teacher was [ __ ] dope
because one time he uh my friend was
being annoying as [ __ ] and my teacher he
was like hey uh Chris let me talk to you
outside real quick yes yeah yeah they go
outside and you just hear him go like
this and slam him again
shut the [ __ ] up in class
and they come back inside and I was like
dude that teacher's dope
hahaha
yeah they don't do that no more huh yeah
I was like dude the age before cell
phone video cameras and stuff where you
couldn't get caught for [ __ ] I was like
oh [ __ ] sometimes you need that I like
that [ __ ] dude I needed that [ __ ] I
needed more of that [ __ ] I was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you just got sunroof that's
great because it's like you either stop
it there or they get released into the
world and be a real [ __ ] yeah and then
the law they get you know they go to
jail because they didn't learn early
yeah yep
you know adios
[Laughter]
[Music]